good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if you've been watching
television recently you've probably
heard the bad news the Trump
administration is over toast cooked done
for good and along with it any hope of
the middle class revolution that 63
million Americans voted for two years
ago the reason for this tragedy is
simple the president has been caught
committing felonies here's what the
legal experts without law degrees are
saying on television
if precedent means anything in the Trump
era Donald Trump will be must be
impeached because of the crimes
prosecutors say he committed in the
michael cohen case both parties need to
get on board to pass articles of
impeachment have conspiracy you have you
have obstruction you have campaigns
finance and you have emolument if the
democrats do not pursue this vigorously
they will be in some ways held
accountable for abdicating their
responsibility it goes to the moral
question the ethical question
democracy's at stake this criminal must
be brought up by the Congress of the
United States for impeachment where I'm
going to show you the Don Lamont tape
there's a lot of emotion there but to
sum up they're telling us that we're
staring down the barrel of a
constitutional crisis and that crisis
stems from what MSNBC describes as quote
the crimes prosecutors say the president
committed in the michael cohen case
which crimes were those we have the
answer the relevant details were spelled
out in a piece that ran over the weekend
in the new york times under this
headline quote prosecutors say Trump
directed illegal payments during
campaign the gist of the story is this
Trump's former lawyer Michael Cohen has
told federal prosecutors that he
facilitated payments to two women who
said they had affairs with Donald Trump
and then well actually that's it that's
the entire story right there paying
these two women say federal prosecutors
and their flacks at NBC News was a
serious crime a crime worthy of
impeachment if not indictment okay but
you might be wondering how exactly is
that criminal well we're gonna explain
it to you we're gonna start by
stipulating that everything Michael
Cowan has told the feds is absolutely
true now assuming honesty isn't usually
a wise idea with Michael Cohen but for
the sake of argument let's do it in this
case everything he says is true why is
what Cowan is alleging a criminal
offense remember the facts of the
stories are undisputed two women
approached Donald Trump and threatened
to ruin his career and humiliate his
family if he doesn't give them money now
that sounds like a classic case of
extortion yet for whatever reason Trump
caves to it and he directs Michael
Cullen to pay the ransom now more than
two years later Trump is a felon for
doing this it doesn't seem to make any
sense oh but you're not a federal
prosecutor on a political mission if you
were a federal prosecutor on a political
mission you would construe those
extortion payments as campaign
contributions you'd do this even though
the money in question did not come from
or go to Donald Trump's presidential
campaign then you claim that Trump and
Michael Cohen violated campaign finance
law because they didn't publicly
disclose those payments despite the fact
that disclosing them would nullify the
reason for making them in the first
place which was to keep the whole thing
secret that is the argument you would
make both in federal court and through
your proxies on cable television
it is insultingly stupid but because
everyone in power hates the target of
your investigation
nobody would question you and that's
what's happening right now
now by this reasoning any money a
political candidate spends to maintain
or protect his image while running for
office now qualifies as a regulated
campaign donation and has to be
disclosed that would include by the way
in addition to an infinite number of
other things buying toothpaste and
getting a haircut it would definitely
include the taxpayer finance slush fund
that Congress is set aside to pay off
its own sexual harassment claims yes
those now qualify as campaign
contributions they must be publicly
disclosed we said of course they're not
publicly disclosed and they never will
be why is that well that might be a
question for congressional leaders
including now that we think about it
congressman Adam Schiff of Burbank
California he's the
coming chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee a very powerful
man in the Congress what does mr. Schiff
have to say about Congress not
disclosing the very same payments that
Democrats say Trump should be impeached
for not disclosing let's ask him there's
a very real prospect that on the day
Donald Trump leaves office the Justice
Department may indict him that he may be
the first president in quite some time
to face the real prospect of jail time
Trump knows that he's facing some pretty
strong criminal liability when he leaves
office one way or another and you know
even if you're sitting president can't
be indicted he's got to know his future
looks like it's behind bars unless he
cuts some sort of deal with the
prosecutors so to translate Trump's a
criminal he's going to jail for
committing a smaller version of the same
made-up crime that we in Congress have
committed for years and forced you to
pay for and by the way we're never
apologizing for that because we don't
have to in CNN isn't gonna make us screw
you America and your stupid election
we're in charge that's the real message
here in case you missed it